et sachez que le pass sanitaire européen
a été actée sous forme numérique et
devra faire état notamment d'une
vaccination contre le coc bidou d'un
test négatif il sera nécessaire pour
passer les frontières européennes
à paris on se mobilise contre
manifestation suivie par notre reporter
j'en attends moi dabo trocadéro à
bonjour jonathan lors quelle est
l'ambiance actuellement ambiances un peu
électriques
jean marie bigard qui vient de
l'humoriste qui vient de s'exprimer au
sujet du comider eu des mots très crus
et là il est en train de piquer une
grosse colère à face à face à la caméra
de nos confrères de deux quotidiens
mais sinon il ya plusieurs personnalités
politiques se sont
mais sur cette scène devant plusieurs
centaines de personnes qui ont bravé la
pluie qui est venue car averses ici au
trocadéro on a vu je reviens philippot
mais aussi le vice-président du sénat
vincent delaigue tous exprimés contre se
passe sanitaire se passa ni terre ce
sera quoi ce sera tout d'abord au niveau
de l'union européenne des 27 pays
européens est mise en place au 1er
janvier
ça permettra de recenser si les gens ou
de tous ils sont testés négativement aux
tests pcr ou antigénique ou encore s'ils
sont les anticorps c'est un passant qui
sent c'est bien faciliter les
déplacements au sein de l'union
européenne et ce même pas ce qui a été
adopté
donc par les 27 pays européens sera
aussi mise en place en france à partir
du 9 juin ça concernera tous les
événements de plus de 1000 personnes ont
passé on pense par exemple à des
festivals de musique des matchs de foot
att est donc jean marie bigard justement
est avec nous monsieur bigard bonjour
jeu on vous a senti très énervé sur la
scène pour quelle raison qu'est ce qui
vous met en colère à ça ça m'énerve que
qu'on administre des gens un vaccin
bidouiller que même le patron de pfizer
refuse de signer culé c'est quand même
un signe
et quand on n'est pas d'accord avec la
pensée unique on devient soi disant un
conspirationniste non non non je serai
des vaccins mais un mec qui veut savoir
pourquoi on administre pour la première
fois depuis le début de l'existence de
l'humanité on administre un vaccin
bidouille et qui n'a pas subi les essais
cliniques
les essais cliniques des vaccins qu'on
nous oblige à prendre n'ont rien suivi
de ces tests habituels ont subi des
nombres et non concernant je remets en
2023 concernant le passé du père
monsieur billardon concernant le pass
sanitaire vous en pensez quoi
c'est une honte nationale compass et
faut absolument mettre un signe
distinctif
exactement comme on l'a fait pour les
juifs à la deuxième guerre mondiale
pourquoi nous mais pas pourquoi dis moi
c'est pas plus pratique de nous mettre
un signe pour dire je ne suis pas
vacciné je me ferais je vais guérir tout
seul avec mon corps et mes anticorps
j'ai pas besoin comme colle dans le
corps une merde qu'ils ne risquent que
de m'apporter des emmerdements
et ce n'est pas vrai qu'elle protège
vous êtes vacciné
vous pouvez plus attraper le virus si
vous pouvez plus transmettre le virus si
alors dites moi pourquoi je me ferai
vacciner
demain au réseau vas-y ça des kouriles
vas-y tu poses des questions réponses
c'est pour le mieux jusqu'au ministre de
la santé en tout cas merci à toi t'es
juste là pour poser des questions bon eh
ben moi je suis là pour donner une
réponse
vous le voyez un jean marie belliard
très très remonté aujourd'hui contre les
autres espaces sanitaires et qui a eu
des beaux seins
très fort et pas forcément très vrai
notamment concernant les tests de
vaccins et ses vaccins sont sont sûrs
donc vous voyez cette ambiance au
trocadéro particulière depuis la prise
de parole de jean marie bigard merci le
temps où une ambiance particulière est
d'ailleurs le patron de pfizer n'a pas
refusé de se faire inoculer le vaccin n
est toujours pas en effet vacciner et
manifestement il attend son cours merci
en tout cas
jonathan pour toutes ces précisions